hey this is the first Sunday after the
atrocities that happened on Wednesday
I've been going around to the different
groups to see if people are talking
about telling Masood are talking about
what happened at Westminster how many
here believe he was a Muslim we do not
hate Muslims do we know do you love this
man
I love this man I love you too do you
love me I love you why do we love
Muslims Allister as Christians where is
this our as our duty to love everyone to
love thy enemy
if two weeks
he's talking about the 230 in Mosul in
Iraq
oh is it Iran this is this is what the
end oh you're changing the subject you
see you don't want us to continue with
the subject do you want to change the
subject foot
there was justification there were
verses he used from the Koran to justify
what he did on that day once he had
destroyed the Jews through now all the
Jews took 800 Jews and cut their throats
in one afternoon where do I get this
from do I make it up Jay I know exactly
what you're talking about
hey where is the sources for what I just
told you you can look at the Quran you
can look at the hadith you can look at
the traditions
can you then see why colleague Massoud
is following that model absolutely
according to the Koran he is absolutely
justified in his actions
yeah okay no no you are you're a
preacher you are a preacher you are like
Isis you are like Isis you're a preacher
Isis you are just like I see a preacher
when you're on the ladder it's all calm
you're a preacher answer my question
exactly though they go where'd you
tumble - down the ladder where's your
tongue gone exactly
well thank you very much that's why
Allah says in the Quran when chief is
spoken posted parish's thank you goodbye
man let me tell you something they do is
they say hey I don't know I don't want
to speak about so I asked a simple
question
very simple show me where in the Quran
does it say Q innocent men women or
children anywhere they claim this and
they preach in hate and this cause it is
the same with Isis what Isis does they
cause hate and innocent people die these
guys do the same they talk about these
matters and innocent Muslims
so on this aesculus show me anywhere in
the Koran that I teaches us Muslims to
kill innocent people and it is one
enough that's about it now 15 bachelors
perfect for the video finishes now as
well in the Dhamma we're in the tower
with different situations and different
circumstances we deal with the matter in
a different way now these individuals
are hate preachers who go out there and
claim this time to terrorism this time
and what this causes and the reason why
I call them that you guys loose is just
that Isis is because what I said you
hate preaching and what does other
people do who watch they stop believing
it and go and kill innocent people
what do these guys do which are similar
they do the same thing hey preaching
Islam as terrorism it's not a she says
it's not a sin to kill innocent people
so what does far-right groups do racist
groups do extremist Christians do look
at this and attack the Muslims they're
innocent Muslims are affected by this
and this is wrong so we want to
challenge them so in the towers
sometimes we have to be firm why because
what they do it is wrong and how do we
do that we do it in the best way
possible because when I confronted this
guy he knows we're a team I did not
assault him I did not shout to him and
he's not attacking I did not do nothing
even though he kind of watching you and
watching me but one German says I'm not
gonna go and do that he's lying about a
religion but they're not our teachers
when I'm gonna go and lie back about
against them we have to be just in
everything that we do and I will say
that in the Quran speak the truth
even if it's against yourself and this
is what we do which is not a simple
question however you renault but when
he's on the matter he asked other way
around that's why i just wanted to
clarify that and one thing I wanted to
say guys is that when giving Dawa our
man is really important as Muslims we
have ambassadors of Islam so we need to
be very calm and collective and have
good manners with people because believe
me is our attitude and behavior that's
people look up you can have all the
knowledge in the world you can be exact
a night quoting the plan versus bang
another man but people don't care about
it they look at a corrupt and your
behavior so this is something that's
really important brothers and sisters so
now I said before have good characters
with those who are honest and genuine
and really want to learn teach them
about Islam don't be harsh with them the
Prophet Mohammed said I did not come for
nothing but a perfect good characters
and one of the things that are gonna be
the heavies on the scale of Deeds on
that day will be la la la la and a
person
character so this'll remind I wanted to
give you guys hope you enjoyed it so my
mother who I met already better care to
my blessing every single one of you guys
take care don't forget subscribe give me
one
thanks honey
subscribe